e
here we go uh good morning everyone
today is uh Wednesday February 19th 2025
and this is a meeting of the
subcommittee of the municipal and County
government to gather additional
information as it pertains to House Bill
432 relative to recovery houses if you
Allegiance I Pledge Your Allegiance to
the flag of the United States of America
and to the Republic for which it stands
one nation under God indivisible with
thank you very much uh okay uh first
person we like to speak to is U fire
Master
Tumi thank you for attending Mr fire
marshall have you had the opportunity to
uh review House Bill 432 relative
recovery houses good morning yeah uh
Sean Tumi State Fire Marsh for the
record uh yes sir I have taken a look at
it um we this is a bill it's very
similar to was introduced last year and
my office was uh involved in the the
definition part of it we were not
involved in the Planning and Zoning
discussion because we feel like that's
not our really Arena to be in but as far
as the definition itself uh we worked
with several stakeholders to try to
refine the definition a little bit um
one of the big things was that crossed
out was that safe healthy family Lake uh
was being crossed out and one of the the
conversation was uh sort of how do you
define safe health healthy and family
like family like's not defined that well
in the codes um and then safe and
healthy was a little bit difficult what
we're relying on is uh in further in
15310 D in the fire code side we have
about a dozen items that are required in
order to meet the requirement for
exemption it talks about egress for
instance um a fire alarm system for
places over eight eight people um it
talks about smoke alarms and carbon
monoxide alarms and heating systems at
work and those types of things and I
think inherently when you follow those
requirements uh and uh are are certified
by one of the certifying groups that
that safe and healthiness kind of comes
with that uh for a well-run house so uh
we were amenable to to removing that as
long as they followed the rest of the
process in that um uh definition the
other big adding the primarily
non-transit dwelling unit um we wanted
to recognize that the people that are
living in a recovering house from our
perspective are there for a period of
time usually these guys behind me I
think could speak far better to it but
you know a year a year and a half is is
pretty customary I believe for someone
that's living in a home it's not a
typical like a motel hotel type
situation where you're in and out in a
day or a couple of days so that people
have a general familiarity with the
house and and uh you know the
whereabouts of of egress and and things
like that so um the the last part of it
uh living as a single household we
wanted to recognize that uh there's a
unit cohesiveness to these uh people
living and Recovery which is part of
their success in in in the the path for
recovery so um you know we again getting
away from the family like because we
can't really Define real well what a
family like is but if you live as a
single household and have the general
whereabouts I've used an example um
actually uh Jonathan's behind me but one
his place is a three family in
Manchester and and I went in there
several years ago and said to one of the
residents on the first floor Hey where's
so and so on the third floor and they
could tell me that exactly they were
working at um you know the restaurant
Dunkin' Donuts or Market Basket down the
street I can't remember the exact
specifics but you know they they knew
where everyone was and there when they
were coming and going and that's uh
that's important to this the the last
part of it and the definition cleanup is
we don't wanted a boarding house or
rooming house cuz those are more of
renting a specific room and you don't
necessarily know about the whereabouts
you you you have your your own room is
locked and it's a very different field
versus the the folks that are living in
recovery and in need that uh
cohesiveness and and kind of living
together to to be successful so happy to
um try to uh answer any questions but I
think the big message is that our office
has been involved in the the defin
definition change uh for the past year
plus and uh you know we're we're
supportive of of the definition change
as it as it's presented thank you
thank you sir uh any questions from the
Frack thank you thank you for taking my
question
um what
requirements or let me rephrase
that in other congregant living
situation such as a group home for
developmentally disabled
people um transitional housing perhaps
for people coming out of the criminal
justice
system are
the Life Safety Code requirements or
exemptions similar or different for what
we're talking about here for the
recovery house thank you for the
question so that there's no exemptions
for those other uses at this point uh
one of the things that we big so we've
been working on this with the recovery
Community since I know I've been since
about 2018 and one of the things that we
learned early on is that um through
federal regulations that um they're uh
classified that they need an
accommodation um and they need um so the
the big thing for this is the sprinkler
system so
the the the I'm going to say family like
even though we just crossed out but
living as a single household which is
the language that we've added in now is
that the people in recovery have to live
as a single household to be uh to be
successful uh have this needs to be a
social certain social model to make this
work and go back to some of these other
congregate living scenarios like the
halfway houses or the transitional
housing or uh some of these other group
homes they're they're more in and out
and there's more of an individual
component to it um that is uh what is
has always been portrayed and and
understood uh as a little bit different
than these recovery houses and they
didn't fit quite as nicely into our code
chapters and that's why we did this
carvo um and there's been some federal
um core cases that have kind of shown
that uh people in recovery uh need to be
treated a little bit differently uh in
this case I think going back to um the
code change I think is that most of
these houses that if they're you know we
need to inspect them because every house
is a little different but if we can meet
the existing chapters which typically
we're talking sprinklers here in almost
all
cases most existing buildings don't
require sprinkler systems and I I think
the the big issue is these are these are
sort of change of uses change of
occupancy in our code world and um you
know we're we're really letting them not
sprinkle the building but they're saying
that where the fallback for us and the
and I think in the cold world is that
they're living under that single
household model that they're
representing or resembling like what
would be in our own homes you know I
think some of our what I've seen is
people living in these big houses that
might have you know six bedrooms and you
put in 12 people in the house two beds
in a in a house and uh it's it's it's a
little bit different than some of those
other occupancies that you spoke about
um and I think that some of the other
you got to be very careful about the
disabilities I think but but
um as uh some of these congregate living
situations exist that have like physical
disabilities or cognitive disabilities
that need that higher level of
protection because of trying to help
upset the ability to get out physically
or something if there people are stuck
in the facility you're going to want
some of these other systems or different
Staffing models to make sure those
people can get out safely and and folks
that are in recovery are able-bodied
like we are and uh you know they're just
they're in recovery and they they can
get out and respond appropriately to a
smoke alarm and get out a window or find
another exit as needed so hope that
answers your question I know it was a
little bit lengthy it does thank you
response represent
Dolan thank you um
and thank you for uh taking my question
uh one of a couple of the concerns that
I have uh if we're not going to require
smoke
alarms uh or at least we're not going to
require them to be checked it it says in
the
legislature uh in the uh legislation
that we're not going to be required to
uh to look at a permit or an approval
process uh so evidently we won't be able
to check for the presence of smoke
alarms or exit signs for example of
someone needs uh a method of erress but
it's if it's at night and there's not
going to be an exit sign for them to be
able to find their way out at night um
and uh so the question I have is uh what
do what can we do to
protect in the inhabitants of a of a
uh a house like this a recovery house
like this not only for the inhabitants
but for the Neighbors I mean in many
cases these houses uh large houses are
adjacent to other structures in the
community that if there's a fire or a
disturbance or whatever it's going to
bleed over it could very very well bleed
over into the adjacent structures what
do we do to protect both the inhabitants
of the recovery house and the Neighbors
in the community thank you yeah so I
think that
um I think we're maybe mixing the two
sections a little bit um because the way
I understand this bill is is written
there's uh left less of an emphasis on
planning and and uh zoning approvals and
site plan approvals which is takes a
more of a hands-off approach as you um
talked about on the Planning and Zoning
sides on the fire code and the building
code sides and especially on the fire
code because it speaks to the chapter
153 which is a state fire code um and I
think the the recovery community that
are here behind me can speak to this but
I there's no intent to push the fire
departments out the the the statute the
the further statute 15310 D actually
allows the fire departments to do annual
inspections of these facilities which is
which is above and beyond which would be
we would normally see in another type of
building so I I think you know the we as
we worked with the recovery community
over the past six seven years to address
this um you know they they've understood
and been uh working with the the fire
departments to allow the annual
inspections which is you know very
different than a typical say apartment
building right if you have an apartment
building I'm going to use Manchester or
Nashville say that was historically a
three or four a two or three family uh
structure that had separate dwelling
separate uh homes and now we've got a a
Recovery House in there that have
multiple people in there that house is
actually being inspected now under 153t
10d by the fire department to make sure
that the fire alarms are working the
smoke alarms are working the egress is
still there the heating systems are
still operating the way they're supposed
to and things like that so I think in
under 153 we have a a lot of uh ability
to get in on annual basis and work with
the recovery house that's the operator
and make sure that the the facilities
are safe thank you as a as a followup um
as a a professional and in your uh
discipline when you're when you
encounter a a proposal for a recovery
house like this uh do you maybe you
could walk through the type of
inspection that you do from a fire
safety uh do you you permit smoking
anywhere in the in the facility do you
require fire
extenders so many per occupant that type
of thing could you walk us through that
sure yeah so each of the recovery houses
that I'm going to try to pull it up
because I don't remember all the points
in detail but uh each recovery house
that's in operation in the State uh over
um usually it's over four people but
they would come and request a a variance
to the fire code from the from our
office uh and one of the inspectors of
my office physically goes out and meets
with each of the operators and walks
through the facility and does an
inspection to make sure that uh as you
said the smoke alarms are good
extinguishers are good and make sure
this contact information available to
reach an owner the street numbers are in
place so they can see you know the fire
department or EMS is responding conf
find the or police if they have to
confine the location of the property
make sure the heating systems uh
inspected annually that the cooking
equipment is in in good shape um I'm
trying to there's no smoking provision
in the building you have to smoke a
certain distance away I believe it's 10
ft please don't quote me exactly on that
it's in the Statue but there's um we go
through that whole inspection uh we work
with the certifying body to make sure
that there's a certification there's a
little Nuance to that that it usually
takes a few for a new upcoming house
there's a little bit of time to get that
certification in place so we give them
usually 6 months to um get the
certification which is an additional
followup to make sure that the recovery
Community the house is running the way
that the certification require which is
above and beyond what we require on the
fire code um so there's a checks and
balances there we want to see that
paperwork submitted to our office and
then that annual inspection process
happens so um any recovery house that's
uh operating I would say legitimately
and and upfront uh which is um a good
number of them comes through our office
and we actually physically walk through
with the local fire department each and
open any other questions yes represent
Walker is the G current code for multif
family homes to have
sprinklers so new if a new building yes
right old one an older not likely unless
there's some reason for it um existing
buildings and existing Apartments um it
depends there's a size component to this
and it's not as as real simple yes or no
but most existing say apartment
buildings do not require a sprinkler
system um over if it's a high-rise
situation then you're in a sprinkler
system scenario but uh most existing are
not required to have them the caveat
that we see a lot of times is if they're
using them for a trade-off for something
else there's an egress problem or
something like that they they'll put
them in after the fact all new
construction over a one and two family
dwelling uh has been required to have
sprinklers for quite sometime cuz if you
if a Recovery House moves into a multi
family dwelling they're all quadrant off
that there's no connection so they're
not like they're like you mentioned a
six-bedroom house that a family used to
live in that could all congregate you
can keep track of each other these are
going to be separate units with separate
locks and all that how does that
pertained for safety codes wouldn't you
want smoke detectors and Sprinklers and
all that stuff in there just for that I
I person I would love sprinklers
everywhere I sprinkled my own own house
but I recognize that's not a fit for
everybody um you know uh I know so
uh my wife in front of me because we
have duplicate smoke alarm systems in
our house but anyways that's a different
story too but uh you know I I think that
uh at the end of the day as long as we
have working smoke and carbon monoxides
alarms in in what we're you know single
family single unit dwellings and good uh
means of Escape or egress that's the
important part right early detection and
warning and getting people out a
sprinkler system uh for these existing
structures is icing on the cake uh and I
think is suitable for you know when
there's a Nuance that we need to address
some uniqueness to it um you
know it's hard to say like I said I'd
like them everywhere but there's the
code has allowed non-s sprinkled
structures existing structures uh for
for a very long time it's very hard to
retrofit it's harder to retrofit some of
these buildings than
uh versus new construction so um I I
feel like I'm dancing around this a
little bit but um you know I I would
love sprinkles everywhere but I guess I
the true is there's there's there's
safety in buildings that are existing
that that are non-s sprinkle there's
there's new construction that's
different uses that are non-s sprinkle
based on size and construction type and
a number of factors so we can have a
safe building being non-s sprinkled um
you know but I think that you there's
there's different requirements that you
can intermingle into that uh
equation I guess to make sure that you
have a safe structure right
so uses over eight people we put our
alarm a residential alarm system which
is a little bit more of belt and
suspenders than our regular smoke or
carbon monoxide alarms that I hope that
we would have in our own homes um
recognizing that people take smoke
alarms down well if you have a monitored
system because you have 8 10 12 people
in a house well if one of those comes
down someone's going to know about the
owner the operator the structure is
going to get notified by that alarm
company
and that alarm is going to go off so we
you know we've worked to try to add a
little bit more um to that I'll go back
to a quick question you had about like
the multistory use a three-story
structure some of the three story
structures they run as sort of three
separate units almost like there's three
three separate entities and the you know
it's locked like it's it's still runs
sort of an apartment but there's more
people there might be six or eight
people in that floor based on the floor
space which is more than what we would
normally be accustomed to but there are
some structures that that whole three
Decker runs as one house and there's no
locks anywhere in the space the bedrooms
aren't locked the uh the doors between
the units aren't locked and it's a free
flow where the first floor living room
might be uh the living room where they
sit and watch TV the second floor one
might have been turned into a space
where they can meditate or do yoga or do
something like that and the third floor
might be used for something a little
different the living room space so um
you know there's there's different
scenarios out there and I think that's
the importance of us getting out in
every one of them to understand the
situation when before they operate and
do these inspections and then understand
what they're doing and and to make sure
that we have a facility that complies
with the the statute in the uh in in the
rules that we have in
place thank
you go ahead repr
Bron hey so I know that you mentioned
that um certification before um and you
said usually you like to see in about 6
months in the in what we have in front
of us it is a year do you think like in
your opinion would we be able to bring
that back to 6 months would a year be a
little bit kind of too much
to I think the uh I want to go back so
we just had a transition a little bit in
some of the the New Hampshire cor's role
and then the New Hampshire partnership
for Recovery residences role recently in
the last I think within the last six or
eight months or so
um and we're trying to navigate the time
I think some of the timelines on that
and and maybe someone behind me might be
better able to answer it um if it just
thinking out loud if it took a year to
make that happen now we still should be
in there before it operates and the fire
departments have the year to get in
there and do an inspection so um I think
the end goal still is important to get
the certification for the the operation
because it helps um provide better for
parameters on how it operates uh but I I
wouldn't I guess I would be flexible I
guess is the best way to say it on on
whether it's 6 months or a year as long
as we can maintain those other uh
parameters in there I think
the I will say that I've been in a lot
of these facilities the ones that are uh
well-run and uh follow these parameters
and are you know follow the
certification process are are great and
then the ones that are the Bad actors
are the problem ones and I think the the
recovery community in general uh wants
to follow the good model is the ones
that you know we is Bad actors in
everything we do sometimes but I think
the the end goal that I've seen over my
years in the fire Marshall's office is
that there's a a great emphasis within
the recovery Community to work to try to
get a a well-run model in there that's
um works for the recovery housing
community and you know follow follows
you know as many of the guidelines as
possible um yeah thank you for that
response and thanks for taking another
question um with that certification if
they if uh one of these were to open up
and not get it in that year do you think
just based on the way this reads makes
me nervous that they could just reapply
and just kind of keep doing that same
process over and over again um I'm not
sure kind of what you think about that
yeah I think uh I I guess I concur with
you there's there's loopholes sometimes
around stuff and I you don't want to if
you can close up some of those loopholes
it's good I think there's also
opportunity sometimes where things take
a little bit longer than need they need
to legitimately I think as long as we
change something there's an an
opportunity somewhere that they can um
ask for extension I guess is and I don't
know who that necessarily would be go to
um but I think that
um I think there's there's people that
try to do things right and stumble on a
roadblock and just need a little bit
more time and I think as long as we have
a mechanism to to work with th those
good any other questions I just have one
for you sir um how many recovery houses
do we have in New Hampshire do you know
that are checked by the fight how much
uh the number is probably a little bit
lower than we would like and I think
part of it's I would say is around the
Planning and Zoning stuff so I think
there's still some that are sort of
underground as we call them because
they're afraid to come to to the surface
and get shut down by you know and put
these people on the street um if I had
to take a wild guest we'd probably have
20 or 24 uh that I know we've we've been
in and certify I can actually get you
the the the exact list um there's more
than that in the state I do know that
but we I just saw um the inspector from
my office that is pretty much dedicated
to looking at these send me four of them
yesterday to to approve um so we're you
know we're working uh closely to keep
doing these approvals as well but this
Planning and Zoning thing is has been a
big challenge I know for the recovery
community that if they um come to the
surface they end up getting closed
closed down so they they try to stand
under the radar and I think that's why
we don't see as many as we we would like
to
sometimes thank you just one more quick
question to uh get that inspection
presently they have to be certified to
get
that so we'll do the inspection without
the certification and give them time to
certification
Dolan thank you um one additional
question uh recognizing that those in in
one of these homes uh is in a category
I'll say one of the more vulnerable in
our community that that needs our help
uh and needs us to look out for them in
the when they're in this uh condition uh
would you if if we pursued an amendment
to this legislation that required
sprinklers would you be in support of
that as I mentioned before I would love
sprinklers everywhere um but I think it
would be a a big detriment to the
operation of these structures overall I
think you would find that most of them
can't achieve that and we' we'd shut
down effectively shut down a significant
number of the recovery houses if we put
that into place say it passed as of July
1 or something like that we would see uh
it would it have a significant impact on
the recovery Community is what I would
think um and I think there's there's
facilities out there that are running
now that are are safe um uh you know
that I guess that would be my my two
cents on that part thank
you any other
questions see none thank you sir for
you okay um William mckenny from New
please morning sir good morning good
morning uh thank you to the commit for
allowing me to speak and inviting me
here today I'm Bill mcken I represent
the New Hampshire building officials
Association um which speaks on behalf of
over 200 code officials throughout the
state of New
Hampshire New Hampshire building
officials Association has worked with
stakeholders for several years on this
project of trying to clarify a path
forward for Recovery Home housing in New
Hampshire recovering H recovery housing
have long had a stigma of being homes
for drug users this is factually UN true
it is important for legislators and
citizens to understand the value of
recovery housing for the rehabilitation
of those who have completed a treatment
program this is the next important step
to substance-free living in New
Hampshire due to recovery houses being a
fairly New Concept in New Hampshire the
building and fire codes and land use
laws did not recognize their use
barriers needed to be identified and
resolved through amendments amendments
to the building of fire codes to Define
recovery homes and include the use in
the codes was completed in the 2024
legislative
session the Amendments made to codes and
requested here in HB 432 help New
Hampshire Better align with federal law
with regards to
disabilities a key component of HB 432
is the requirement for certification
through a recognized organization that
has clear standards of operation
boarding a rooming houses have no
required certification and therefore do
not have the same standards of
operation the certification process for
Recovery homes bring a higher Comfort
level to code officials that the
required standards are being regularly
monitored that is an important piece of
recovery housing over again boarding
houses or rooming
houses no certification a loss of the
certification brings much more stringent
building and fire code requirements into
play Recovery homes do get some waivers
as you've heard from the Fire Marshall
as far as sprinkler systems if they are
not a certified home they lose that that
waiver and then they would they would
now have to look at sprinkling that
building as a rooming or a boarding
house amending the land use law in HB
432 is the next step to addressing the
barriers that prevent recovery houses
that is necessary to helping curb the
addiction problems in New Hampshire and
with that I'll be glad to take any
questions from the
committee thank you any questions uh
represent Dolan thank you for taking my
question uh do you believe that these uh
buildings and the use of these buildings
Compliant if the if the federal
guidelines were to require that then yes
um however under the homes having not a
change of use not having alterations
that exceed 50% of the florer of the
building um they wouldn't require Ada
upgrades if they did alterations to the
buildings um and again if they if if it
was classified as a change of use which
it isn't under the codes in this case
then the Ada M the Ada or accessibility
under the building code would would um
apply but again under a one or two
family dwelling that's still being
utilized as a one two one or two family
dwelling access the accessibility in Ada
apply any other
questions yes sir represent
walker uh my understanding of the the
exemptions that they're getting what
kind of
zoning and local exemptions do they have
what particular codes do they going to
get exempt from or
waved good question uh I can't speak to
the zoning um I I I don't I only dabble
that in my profession um um but um as
far as the exemptions that they receive
Mo most the the largest one is the um
sprinkler system that they can apply to
the State Fire Marshalls off office and
receive a waiver from sprinkler systems
which is a very costly um system to
install in some areas almost almost
impossible when you think about some of
the rural areas where some of these
homes may be um the uh as far as zoning
exemptions that would be left up to the
individual communities um to DET
determine whether they can get an
exception through either a waiver
variance okay thank
morning
e
questions thank you Mr chairman uh I
have a couple of questions if you'll
indulge me um do you would you agree
that that there are in our population
people
uh that need to be in a recovery house
disability thank you for the question
representative Dolan um I would agree
with components of that statement U
there are obviously individuals in the
community that need support of uh living
in a household unit perhaps of with
individuals that are having a similar
experience or dealing with similar
challenges uh what I would perhaps add
as Nuance that statement is simply that
they living in that format or in that
household typology should not
necessarily mean that
they perspective certainly the does
exist in the community thank you and uh
how how do you
address those individuals that seek
recovery who can't use the
bathroom or who can't don't have access
in and out of the front door how how do
you deal with that and and and that we
might find in in these
cases thank you for representa and I
don't know if I can speak to the details
of the operations and I think that's
what you're getting to as as a regulator
necessarily
go ahead
representative uh thank you um looking
at the multif family structure part of
it I'm not sure how many of those that
you have in nasua um but could you speak
to if you do have them um is there any
data that it is effective for the people
living in these homes and kind of what
the effect is on the community around
those it's a great question thank you
representative for
that obviously in the city of Nashville
we allow recovery housing a variety form
single
I just have a quick question you require
certification in ASA for Recovery
House mdon we do not require
certification
c one of the benefits of course sub
certification is that it's a very
over and public uh representation that
that recovery home is operated in a
manner that's consistent with best
practices and for Community interests
but we do not require certification uh
in fact it's those that do not require
certification that have
often so I can't speak enough to the to
the necessity of the certification
process but it's not
requir another quick question for you if
you do have issues with an non-certified
Recovery House how do you enforce or
what laws do you have regulations to
thank you any other
questions rep Walker do you have any uh
police data on those 30 houses how many
trips how many
that sort of
thing I don't in front of me today I
could certainly provide some of that
information um anecdotally we've had we
have had discussions though and we don't
see increased frequency for for all of
those homes we have had some problematic
locations in the city uh but again no
more than other households where we have
regular disturbances but if that's
something the committee might be
interested certain that would be that
okay any other
questions thank you Mr s for coming in
in
e
thank you our
questions represent Doan uh thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
question uh as you can tell by my
previous questions I'm I'm a little
concerned about ada8
compliance um in
nashwa uh how many um exceptions have
you taken taken for Nashville city hall
not being ADA
Compliant thank you for the question
representan specifically to City Halls
accessibility right I I don't have in
let me say that that I'm going to assume
that you're fully ADA Compliant at the
city hall uh
and the question in context is uh if
that's what you're offering to the
community so people have access whether
they're uh disabled or not that they
have access to their local government
um the concern I have is when somebody
who may be disabled that wants to use uh
one of these these homes uh may not have
access uh and therefore you're creating
a you might be creating a double
standard in the community if you want to
go to the town hall you have full access
if you want to go uh to a recovery house
you don't so uh that's consideration
that that I offer back that that you
might want to think about uh how you how
you might want to deal with that and I'm
interested in your comment about that
and I I don't mean to create a an an
unanswerable question but it's a thought
that's going through my my mind and in
the context of here we have some very
vulnerable people in our community that
we want to help yet we may be denying
them access to the house that they may
have to live
much
Walker so I'll ask you the same question
how many or what type of exceptions or
waivers would from the zoning would a
recovery house get certainly um so as we
currently regulate them um none however
we do have some regulations that do come
into apply that that create you know
some guard rails around these one of
which is is regulating um unrelated
occupancy whereas currently we have a
regulation that that bases occupancy
thresholds on the type of building
sometimes the type of
and we have a table in our ordinance
that basically says take a single family
you would be allowed one unrelated
occupy one unrelated occup for
300t Li for the example of a 3600 foot
home that would be 12 individuals now
you can turn that on his head a little
bit and say well you can have a really
large family where they are related
individuals when we talk about this this
regulations really in terms of making
don't expose neighborhoods to
overs undo density of Ops um
but a natural family um would would not
be subject to that um this is a
regulation that is accepted under the
Fair Housing Act um obviously though it
does you look at it you are treating
people differently based on their
related or unrelated status um but that
is one of the r which uh someone coming
to establish this use um May seek some
various relief from that um only
considers context neighborhood building
typology things like that but we have
not actually seen any of these requests
associated with this sort of use I think
that might just be inded that the
thresholds and the standards around our
you didn't exactly give me a number but
are you asking for a number of
regulations that you have waivers for
for a recovery huh so so that would be
the one regulations just one yes because
we don't actually have recover hous
established as a use the way we treat it
is whatever the building is so this is
right in line This legislation that
proposed if it's a single family home
it's being treated as a single family
home subject to their occupancy
standards on that single bilding line
the table um so that's really the key
thing if a building is being developed
built you know setbacks law area
standard dimensional regulations that go
along with site development would still
apply but it's no different a recover
home any use the OCC if you took a
single family home very large one that's
in a single family zoned area and it
gets
more rooms get made or whatever to to
more people go into that single family
home than normal would that be allowed
again it's going to come down to that
one person for 300 sareet um so yes new
bedrooms could be made but the way our
code operates it's not based on it's
square footage of the building all told
so they can make as many me as they want
but they're still constrained by
yes sir represent Frack
please thank you um in Nashua do you
differentiate your occupancy codes on
areas that are served by Town sewer Town
water versus more rural areas where you
any other
questions represent Doan please one
quick question thank you Mr chairman um
permitting or approval process is is
limited for this application this
legislation uh
what input do uh local
residents uh in in particular uh
neighbors uh
of projects like this what what
opportunity do they have to provide
input to folks like you and people who
run the local government about uh their
certain
use on the general scale that we're
seeing them where it's a single building
that's a change of use that's an
administrative approval there is no
public hearing before planning rule so
in that instance there there is no
public process
um you look at what the impact is you
know obviously I think you do have
chances where you could go a bit
extremely having a very large
individual
hopefully exous
concerns but because it's really just a
conversion use but at the same time the
use is relativ similar it's just it's
now
indidual in my professional opinion
that's not something that would rise the
level of ACC a public hearing simply
because
not
termity or other concerns and I do want
to speak to the fact that this
legislation is requiring certification
and I think that that
adds important distinction and I think a
level of comfort to the
resen signant
you
Frank thank you
um most development projects that I'm
familiar
with that require some sort of a
certification or public hearing the
certification happens prior to the start
of the
development and in the case of recovery
houses they are given a period of time
whether it's six months or 12 months is
irrelevant but the uh the point being
that the house needs to be up and
running before the certification
Authority can provide that
certification my question
is it's kind of not the normal way of
doing things the normal order and how
how has that been received amongst the
broad community of residents in the city
of Nashua
um well I don't think that I'd be able
to speak to you know the general public
in nation's perception of this
particular element of the bill um but I
will speak
to how I would see that how we would
operate through
that I have no concerns about the
substantial race where you do get up and
running but you are required to seek
this I think that's a fine way to
operate understanding that know of
operators
that
certific but I do think that what this
legislation provides level of protection
radiator speaking um but that book being
you do have to
aeve I think that there is some
exercises that need to ur what does
happen not achieve certific
is
State
local thank
you go ahead
representative thank you going back to
that certification um do you think that
with the year it's that right now that
it could be cut back to maybe 6 months
with additional time if you're working
with the
municipality I think that it could I
don't necessarily see a benefit to
cutting it back I think it amount of
time um I also don't believe that I
would be the right person to really
answer that I don't know certification
process I don't know if achiev
certification in six months is actually
um so I wouldn't want to say that you
let's let's cut it down to six
any other questions I just have a quick
question for you um the city nro seems
to have addressed a lot of the things
locally within this bill as far as
regulating the the recovery houses why
do we need this bill shouldn't this be
done at the local level rather than
through the state that's a that's a very
good question
um I will say that I think that we are
in n a bit of an outl simply because we
have so many of these and we seen them
and they've actually been challenged INT
in different ways where we are kind of
at the point of this year navigating
again the relationship between local
regulations and federal law I think that
Anthony salvi I hope I didn't miss penoa
sir my name is Anthony salbuchi I am the
Director of Business Development
community relations of the New Hampshire
Coalition of recovery
residences um we are a certifying agency
here in the state of New
Hampshire um I am Rising today in in
support of House Bill
432 um this bill is extremely important
to uh solidify a definition of recovery
housing in the state of New Hampshire uh
as many previous speakers have have said
today um the stigma and and the nuances
of the planning and development
processes can become cumbers cumbersome
uh throughout the state and limit the
ability to open up suitable and safe
drug and alcohol-free housing in every
community in this uh in this great state
um New Hampshire Coalition of recovery
residences partnered up with uh the
Fletcher group and performed a study um
on the amount of home homes that were
needed in the state of New Hampshire uh
and that was estimated at
15,000 um and after conversations with
nhpr and ourselves I believe there's
approximately 108 certified homes and
only
1340 uh certified beds in the state um
so we have a significant shortfall and
it is imperative that we all begin to
address this and I think the first step
is having a common understanding of what
recovery housing is what recovery
housing provides um and how recovery
housing is intended to slip in and
become part of any Community uh and any
neighborhood that uh the operator
chooses to open um I am in support we
are fully in support I can provide you
with the Nar standards of certification
and I'm available to answer any uh any
questions you may
have we d thank you Mr chairman 1 1300
beds in the state what's your estimate
as to how many beds do we really
need um as stated they estimate
15,000 1300 to 15,000 right right now we
have 1300 and after the study with the
Fletcher group it is 1
you goe
representive thank you um in your
experience kind of as these um homes get
bigger and we get into the multif family
use um is there evidence or data
somewhere that this is still an
effective method for the people living
living in those homes and that it's
still um kind of the impact on the
community I don't have any of that data
in front of me I'm sure we could uh work
with some of our partners and and also
with the National Alliance of recovery
residents and try to collect some of
that data um a little bit more globally
and uh and I'll provide it to to this
committee uh once we rece receive it um
but what I will say is the social model
of recovery is the gold standard
throughout the United States of America
um and it is imperative and important
that these homes operate with
uh larger than normal size I guess as
you would compare to a single family use
um because of the fact that those
individuals within that home are relying
upon the other individuals that are
going through the same challenges
concerns thought process
uh struggles um and they rely on one
another without that support next to you
um or without ample support in that home
suffer go ahead
representative yes
uh the majority of the the recovery
homes around or single family or two
family do you have how many what's the
percentage for like multifamilies do you
have is that something new that you're
pursuing I I don't have that count in
front of me um what I could say is they
they do range from one two and three
family homes uh
yes represent
Frank thank you
um changing the focus of the discussion
just a bit here uh excuse me our rec
recovery houses are set up as a business
is that a valid
assumption it's like any other real
estate uh in LLC or or a particular
owner will uh purchase the building and
then either lease it or operate the
recovery residents themselves so they
would file business filings but for all
intents and purposes the home does not
operate as a business it operates as a
single family there is not Brook brick
and mortar foot traffic uh that that is
going to be coming into that home so
that gray area tends to be something
that indiv you know individuals jump
towards uh in in an opportunity to raise
the stigmatic approach of of recovery
housing and preventing them from coming
to the area but the reality of it is is
the individuals living within that home
are living as a single family unit and
and the business is recovery in that
house so are are the businesses set up
as
nonprofits or profit making
entities uh we have both entities
throughout the state of New Hampshire um
some are nonprofit um but again NH core
along with Fletcher group did a study um
and found that it is um sign
significantly more uh expensive to
operate a recovery home as a nonprofit
than as a for-profit business due to uh
additional positions that are within
those boards and and those
organizations uh which translates down
to a more uh expensive housing fee for
individuals that are that are seeking
that housing so we have both in the
state of New Hampshire and they'll
they'll submit whatever appropriate
taxes um that they should be but the
majority of homes in New Hampshire are
uh not nonprofit organizations
thanks repr
Walker that brings up a subject in my
mind do the individual people people
living in these homes pay rent or is
there how is the payment rent
transaction done so there's no rent and
Recovery housing there is a housing fee
or a fee for service um but there is no
landlord tenant relationship between
those individuals because of the fact
that a normal landlord tenant uh
situation wouldn't allow him to remove
someone from the home for consuming uh
drugs or alcohol uh whereas recovery
residences need to ensure that the
remainder of the residents of the house
are are able to live uh free from drugs
and alcohol so uh that we call them
housing fees typically uh the individual
is expected to pay that out of pocket
there are numerous uh scholarship and uh
state and federal funding that is
available uh through the doorways of New
Hampshire as well as some other
nonprofit organizations uh that will
assist uh but the goal longterm is to
get these individuals to uh obtain 40h
Hour Week gainful employment or
uh whether that be you know working
full-time volunteering
full-time uh or any combination thereof
or attending schooling to become a more
uh competitive individual in the
employment Market as they move to
Independent
Living uh the purpose is
[Music]
to have them pay their own fees so that
they understand what it's going to be
like as they move on to Independent
Living too much funding and too much uh
additional money can be considered uh
enabling there is conversations
throughout uh the federal government
right now that is considering uh a
Medicare Medicaid payer paye Insurance
situation but there that has not come to
fruition and clearly with the uh new
Administration there's some uh some
uncertainty how that's going to proceed
in the
future if I may right sir the tenant
landlord situation if you violate your
lease or you do some drinking or
whatever drugs in the house you can be
evicted but that eviction process can be
30 60 days if a person in a Recovery
House disrupts the breaks the rules
relapses and uses drugs on premises how
is that handled by the recovery house um
so there every house uh may handle it a
little bit differently but there is an
expectation through NH core as a
certifying body I will not speak for
nhpr they uh have a representative here
as well um but for NH core it is
expected that all uh recovery homes
operate with a relapse plan um some
residents have individuals sign it upon
arrival where kind of gives them a
breakdown of what that would look like
there is the safety of the other
residents that we have to keep in mind
keeping someone that is uh intoxicated
or under mind altering uh drugs or
alcohol cannot remain in that house so
typically what the the process would be
is the individual be uh confronted or UA
in order to determine if they had
consumed illegal drugs or alcohol um and
then there would be a discussion on
whether or not that if it is positive
whether or not that individual wanted to
go to a respit in order to provide uh
some time in order to provide a clean
year analysis to come back to that home
if that is an option there's been no
other safety issues uh that go along
with the relapse um they can elect to go
back into a treatment PHP IOP
inpatient um but we have to also
remember that these individuals are not
incarcerated they are not required to be
in recovery housing so they also have
the option to uh leave and go to a
friend's house if that's what they
choose to do or um at their own expense
get a hotel operators are are educated
appropriately as well as their house
leadership on the fact that individuals
need to be placed in a safe location if
that is an option so we want them
communicating with that individual um
one of the houses in particular that
I've spoken to um then I have some
knowledge of it's a requirement upon
arrival to select what option you would
have in the event of a
reoccurrence and uh if there is that
reoccurrence we're able to kind of look
back at the resident and say you're
changing your mind right now on
something that sober you said was a
better idea maybe you should listen back
to who you are um and then they'll
they'll bring them on to that that
respit that IOP or that
PHP thank
you represent Dolan thank you Mr
chairman um as we look at recovery
houses in this
context uh typically those in recovery
have good days and bad days sometimes
they fall out of
recovery uh and uh we tend to call that
a
cases how often do you require law
enforcement to be
involved and or mental health
professionals to intervene or something
similar to that we currently don't track
that data
specific I'm sorry I didn't haveit my
microphone you're able to if you have to
repeat the record no I don't think
so um yeah I don't have that data
directly in front of me um I can say
from my personal experience um we've had
interactions with
of false alarms from the from the system
thank
you Le
Jam thank you can you uh speak to that
process of gaining that certification
and kind of what that timeline looks
like sure I mean it's a comprehensive
stand
are
e
actually have a followup go ahead
perfect um so do you believe that the
way it's written here that there is a
chance someone could abuse it and just
keep reapplying for that
certification in terms of of re or abuse
I would say no right this is
not the way I view this bill
is the individuals that are going to be
will as well as the planning board and
and the certifying body which would by
default the uh e gu uh these individuals
it's an expensive Endeavor to try to try
to push off and I guess Carri on on the
top of that is the fact that once you
great thank
you represent Frank thank you um has
your
organization or any of its members ever
had any conversations with Dees or with
Town
officials about occupancy levels that
exceed the design parameters for the
property
e
any other
questions I just have a a couple uh I
contacted Health and Human Services and
how many recovery houses do you have
that are part of your group right now
part of nh4 specifically yeah we are the
last time I spoke with our certification
specialist was Friday last week it
was7 okay those are ones that are being
certified you have members that not
certified that belong to the group no
okay now how does a work with the
registry there's a voluntary registry I
guess through Health and Human Services
how does that relationship work so um
currently New Hampshire Partnership of
recovery residen is is the sole
Hampshire we're working with with the
state at this time to to discuss that
nh4 has been the certified body
that
to that it is not the home that you are
just another quick
followup how do I lose my certification
who checks the certification is it
yearly or once they get it is that there
forever or how does it work yeah so
annually and Rees that every home
certified ised that includes another
upload and
by as well as an additional walk to that
they
process which is opport for individual
to
[Music]
what happens if a uh a recover this law
is passed and Recovery house uh goes and
opens up and they lose the certification
what's going to happen to that house
they can still operate
or can you think of any penalties that
would that could
apply if if I I passed the first time
around my certification I this law
passes two years later I lose my
certification what protection are is
there there to make him get that
certification again so they comply with
the law so we're not typically unless
it's truly egregious we're not going to
roke certification in that nature there
would be some kind of action plan
establ with that so we would follow up
policy out we would notify that they had
my suggestion is that if individuals are
do have their certification
remok and it's egg enough that
certifying body they
appropriate municipality the appropriate
action NH and I don't want to speak but
I'm pretty confident that they feel the
same way uh we don't want that happening
this this statute is to bring people to
the
certific seeking this
bill are the ones that are coming to
certification thank you any other
questions represent Frack yeah how do I
know as either a potential resident or
as a member of the community if a
particular house is certified not
certified or is not current on its
certification how is that information
any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much for coming in appreciate it thank
appreciate uh B the from the New
thank you Mr Vice chairman and thank you
to the subcommittee for uh letting me
speak today for the record my name is
bro Dees I represent the nire municipal
Association and we currently oppose the
bill as written I've learned a lot
meeting with some of the other
stakeholders that are currently in this
room about um about recovery homes and
how they're regulate in different
municipalities how they're regulated by
the state and the federal government our
biggest concern is that um this bill
would mandate that all recovery homes be
treated as single family two family or
multif family use in every um zoning
ordinance across the state um it would
prevent municipalities from regula
regulating recovery homes that qualify
as congregate living in their zoning
ordinances I use that term specifically
because it's used in Keen zoning
ordinance and they have a pretty
comprehensive zoning ordinance on what
congregate living is and what types of
uses fall under that um and many
recovery homes are utilized as congrate
living spaces and being owned and
facilitated by nonprofits or for-profit
institutions so sometimes they're owned
sometimes they pay the people's um rent
or the quote fees that they'll pay to
the landlords um this also amends a
definition of quote recovery homes be
quote primarily non-transient dwelling
or dwelling units which in our opinion
is not an accurate depiction of recovery
homes and their usage in every single
municipality um we heard some of that in
the testimony that you guys received a
few weeks ago um we believe that by the
very nature recovery homes are not
dwellings that they are dwellings that
serve as a transient population there's
no expectation that they stay there for
a very extended period of time there's
an expectation that eventually they need
to leave and go on to Independent Living
um I want to point out there was a
hearing yesterday in front of the house
housing committee on house bill 457
which is a more expansive mandate that
allows congre living or group homes in
all residential zones and um congregate
or group living versus regular dwellings
is very different imagine the difference
between your house or your apartment and
dormitories right dormitories have those
those communal spaces where there's a
communal kitchen communal um bathrooms
you know everyone has shared Wastewater
and shared trash disposal um you have
different rooms sometimes they can be
locked sometimes they're unlocked um
versus our house you know or an
apartment that we may live in um you
know you have all your own bathrooms you
have your own you know locked door your
entire unit your dwelling is closed off
to others you're not sharing your
kitchen with your neighbors um you might
share a hallway if you live in an
apartment building um if you live on a
single family you know residence that's
a house you have your own lot to
yourself so um so these concret living
situations are much different as a use
versus what we what I'm going to call
for the purposes of this discussion
regular dwellings and there's an
interest to regulate for safety health
and uh General Welfare especially
General Welfare congrate living
situations differently than um Regular
dwellings whether it be single family
dwellings um two family dwellings or
multif family dwelling um housing and
congrate housing is a change of use in
some zoning ordinances in some
municipalities across the state it's
actually not a lot that regulate
congrate living but it tends to be
college towns or places where you know
that are higher density or urban areas
um where people might try to um become
roommates or where um College landlords
might try to lease out per bedroom and
so you might have per bedroom occupancy
um zoning ordinances to try to prevent
um you know too many people from living
in One Singular dwelling and making sure
that congrate living dwellings are away
from single family neighborhoods or two
family neighborhoods because again their
usage is different and their uh impact
on a community's infrastructure traffic
and especially parking is um is much
different than a single family dwelling
um unrelated people living together too
um are much different behave differently
than families just for an example cars
right if you have a family of five
you're still likely going to have only
two cars um if you have eight people
living in a congrate living situation
it's more likely each person's going to
need a car because the reality in New
Hampshire is we don't have a lot of
public transit people need to drive to
get to work so and they can't
necessarily always carpool because I
might work you know one's one hour West
and the other one's 1 hour East so
municipalities have an interest of when
there's a change of use requiring as
part of the variance and site plan uh
review making sure that there's
additional parking and it works with the
current traffic patterns especially in
dense
areas um and this is especially true
with leases by bedroom if you do lease
by bedroom um I'm not sure if recovery
homes would do it that way but with
congr living situations you might have a
lease by bedroom recovery homes are a
little bit different as as we've
discussed they're there are fees that
they pay but um still those fees could
be a fee per bedroom that you live in
and um if all of a sudden you decide
well I don't want to pay the fees to
live in this recovery home I'm going to
go live in another one well they'll
probably fill someone else and so then
that's more of a a transient use too um
zoning ordinances they do help and they
don't hurt the ability of municipalities
to have safe responsible development uh
it's trying to make sure that specific
uses are done in zones that have been
developed for 40 50 60 years to be able
to deal with that infrastructure impact
of whether it's congrate living multif
family dwellings or single family
dwellings um and whether the waste water
is discharged to the sewer system or
done through a traditional septic
on-site Wastewater disposal um I'd like
to really stress again site plan
approval is important when you're doing
the parking and the traffic planning if
you require um more parking spaces um
also the threshold for conget living in
many zoning ordinances is typically
aligned with a fire code so four
unrelated people so it's not an
arbitrary number it's kind of aligned
with the fire code because there might
be additional um modifications that need
to be made to the dwelling to ensure
that it's in accordance with the um the
fire code also regulating congr housing
is not discrimination it's about the
property and the dwelling use not those
who are using it or trying to change the
use now if someone was let's say let's
say um an organization nonprofit or
for-profit facilitating um recovery
housing wanted to use a multi family
dwelling so it had six units or seven
units eight units and they wanted to
make it so that each unit someone who is
in recovery would live in there um or
they could even do it so there are two
unrated people living in each um
dwelling unit that's not change of use
in many zoning ordinances that's still a
multif family dwelling now if all of a
sudden if it's a single family dwelling
and you're putting four five six people
or even in a multi-dwelling unit you're
trying to put more than four people in
each dwelling unit then it becomes congr
use the use changes and typically you
need to go get a variance um I'd like to
also mention you know multi again so
that's a distinction so multif family is
not congregate use there's multif family
use there's congregate use um and any
municipality can adopt the language in
this legislation on their own it sounds
like to me the previous municipality
spoke that they've adopted a lot of
these things in their ordinances um and
it's their belief that that's a benefit
to their Community um we've had more
municipalities tell us that this mandate
would make it harder for them to have
safe responsible zoning ordinances that
promote the health welfare and safety of
their municipalities um I'd also like to
point out that if a for-profit is
commercial use uh that's also a change
from residential to commercial if it's
it's owned by a for-profit or it's being
used by a for-profit so um so that's
something that would impact it too so
all of a sudden if any for-profit were
operate a dwelling unit in any Zone as a
um as a recovery home you know we'd have
concerns that they would try to maybe
mix the Waters of is this really a
residential use versus a commercial use
um you know to to the vice Chairman's
point this is part of the reason why
these are dealt with locally and by the
voters of adopting ordinances and I'd
also like to point out that um many
communities don't regulate congregate
living situations and the reason why is
because of many small municipalities
it's not an issue right if you have you
know six unrelated people who decide to
rent a home on a 2 acre lot that's you
know zoned for you know or that has like
a three-bedroom or a four-bedroom septic
system there's no impact on the abutters
or the municipality or its
infrastructure but where this really
becomes a problem is where they are
regulated which is denser areas and
College towns so um it's our belief that
those communities have developed over a
you know multi-decade period to ensure
that each zoning district has a capacity
and the ability to deal with the types
of dwellings and how the dwellings are
used and it's probably best to not um
disrupt that reasonable and and planning
that's been done for decades and um I'll
take any questions if you guys have
any thank you Mr Des what questions from
Mr
Des see thank you for coming minute sir
thank
you okay uh I have one more card left
and that's Jonathan Gerson did you want
to talk joh yeah okay thank
you
hi hi uh I'm Jonathan Gerson uh I'm an
operator so I thought I'd I'd sit up
here and give you uh my perspective
without giving you a whole Spiel I'd
rather just open it up to you know some
questions but just to give you a little
bit of my background um
go the uh agency is into action so we're
living um we've been operating since
2017 um we have homes for men and homes
for women um all the homes are certified
um I've been doing the work uh also as
an advocate um I support new operators
you know throughout the state I have
been in front of many zoning boards in
front of many planning boards um both on
behalf of my own homes uh projects that
I wanted to attempt in other
municipalities uh and also for those PE
you know those people that I work with
and I've seen the challenges of not
having uh a definition of recovery
housing um I've seen it play out and
I've been in a lot of uh zoning and
planning board meetings where um the
board itself um wanted to support the
application
but naturally uh the nimi issues come up
and the entire
neighborhood comes out in full
force and the zoning board's hands are
tied despite them wanting to support the
application um typically our type
of uh I don't want to speak I don't want
to speak legally but typically it
doesn't seem we meet the variance
criteria specifically
um all the criteria and where we're
looking for a reasonable accommodation
under the Fair Housing Act um many
zoning boards and planning boards around
the state don't seem to be prepared to
um really rule on those types of
applications so again I I've seen
municipalities zoning boards planning
boards want to support these homes and
have these homes in their Community they
work with rcos you know Community
organizations healthc Care organizations
and they all want these homes they do
because they know that they
work but they don't have any and they're
not going to have any because operators
like me wouldn't dare go to certain
cities and towns in the state because we
know we
know um so having this
defined um because as a residential use
and bringing the part parties that
really know how they operate which would
be the State Fire Marshall's office who
you've heard from because this the way I
read this legislation it
requires us to notify the municipality
hey we're here we're we're here which
then requires us to notify State Fire
Marshall's office have them do their
walkthroughs um and it also requires us
to notify uh the certifying body and and
maintain certification so now you have
the all the parties that really should
be providing oversight of of these
recovery houses so what you're going to
have is you're going to
have the good there are a lot of good
homes out there and this I think would
remove some of those quote unquote Bad
actors
that you've maybe heard some of the
complaints about because I would like to
say I think I'm one of the good actors
and a lot of people have success in our
homes uh and we need homes like like I
provide and like a lot of other people
like myself provide um so I'm here to
answer any questions you might have
thank you what questions do we have uh
representative Walker what size home do
you run so we have eight um and they're
all different um so we have two types of
houses we have a
the more structured house which we
certify is what's called a level three
house is some more support there's more
uh for example in a level three house
they do a morning meditation every
morning together um they have their
weekly house meeting they're provided
some recovery support case management
from somebody offsite that doesn't live
there um and those are level three homes
um we have uh in those homes we have
three men's homes those are those are
approximately 18 men uh they're large
homes they're all approximately 4,500
5,000 square ft total square
footage um and then we have three uh two
smaller women's homes uh then those are
one is a single family and one is a two
family uh those have 11 women um and
then the remaining three homes are what
we what I call a phase 2 home these are
for people that have been with us for
about a year uh they meet certain other
criteria they've been St you know stable
employment for long period of time they
Mee in certain uh recovery goals um we
do practice a 12-step program so they
have to have met certain you know
accomplishments in that program again
stable employment uh and some other
things been compliant with all of our
house requirements for an extended
period of time uh once they once they
are at that point and they choose to
step down to a phase two uh home um we
we do have those options for both men
and women um less less structure there's
a reduction in the cost to their weekly
fee um and uh and those homes one is a
single F
uh they're all single family they're all
single family how many bedrooms
about
um one of them is uh five
bedroom two of them are five
bedroom and
and the other one is six bedroom thank
you followup great the I can see I've
been on a planning board in Rochester
for 18 years so you know about a
property oh yeah and I can tell you you
are going to run into problems with
zoning boards just the way they're
designed because you have to meet their
five criteria for hardship right and I
don't think you probably don't meet one
of them cuz it's not designed for that
sort of thing correct so that's a that's
a tough hurdle to get around correct and
the planning board you're right you're
going to have all the the neighborhood
come out in the planning board and I
have public input
and I can see some planning board
members getting uh yeah kind of
concerned that they're going against
what the community wants so I think you
do have a tough road to go through that
kind of permanent system but I think
it's a necessary one because
I it's it's a complicated issue
I know we've had uh a lot of uh
boardrooms filled with people because of
boarding houses because oh man did the
neighborhoods come out against the
boarding room houses in in certain
neighborhoods so I can see you getting
into a dense neighborhood is going to be
difficult you're more have to be on
the less less dense
areas thank you okay I represent Dolan
may I add one one thing to that um so uh
again my I've tried projects in in other
cities and towns that I I couldn't move
forward in uh after some obstacles and
challenges in front of zoning or
planning but so primarily uh I do
understand Manchester very very well um
and what's unfortunate is the way the
zoning map is laid
out if you follow the zoning map and and
the zoning ordinance where it's
identified as congregated housing in the
interpretation is we are congregate
housing according to their table of uses
then you are only allowed in the
toughest neighborhoods in the city and I
would I do want to say that those are
some of the neighborhoods that people in
recovery desperately need to
escape and um so yeah I want to say that
as well I don't disagree with that
that's not exactly a place that you want
someone in recovery in right too many
Temptations or influences that could be
detriment yeah thank
you he representative Dolan please thank
you Mr chair uh thank you for taking my
question you you seem to um indicate
that you're aware that many zoning
boards would like to have more recovery
houses but they're reluctant to approve
it probably because of adverse public
reaction to it are you looking
for us in the legislature to
mandate that the zoning boards approve
recovery
housings I think by having a definition
of what recovery housing is would be
incredibly helpful um because again I've
been in front of I don't want to name
the municipality but a very small
municipality so the zoning ordinance I
don't even think it was adopted until
like 2005 their first zoning ordinance
there was nothing even close remotely
close in their ordinance to what we do
um and so it was almost impossible to
even give a
proposal um it would be very helpful in
trying to uh present an
application or uh you know uh to be able
to open an a recovery house uh if there
was a definition for it does uh as
followup does this legislation fulfill
that requirement in your mind to offer
yes any other questions go ahead sir
thank you um in your experience with
those larger houses is it still as
effective for each person that walks in
the door as it would be for some of the
houses with fewer people in them in
terms of staying sober and kind of
staying with that mission to um stay
clean and kind of move
on absolutely and it was for me just you
know and complete disclosure I moved up
here from Boston uh I'm a Massachusetts
transplant I love New Hampshire I came
up here in uh early 2016 and uh I moved
into a recovery house one of the few
that was around back then in New
Hampshire we I think there was about
five or six and and I came up here and
into a house of about 18 to uh no 19
guys and it saved my life um there's a
sweet spot I have noticed that the women
women's homes do better little smaller
size men seem to do well in more of a
fraternity type Brotherhood than uh uh
the women's homes do so smaller homes
for the women's at least for interaction
sober
living any other questions I just got a
couple uh how long would you usually
stay in recovery house you mentioned a
couple of different phases I guess so
when I do a phone screen uh with so I do
the phone screens for the men um I have
a I have a recovery case manager that uh
does all the women's phone screens I try
to keep a uh uh some distance um and um
but when I do a phone screen I always
recommend a minimum of six of or I ask
for an an agreement a commitment to 6
months but I recommend one year um and I
was actually just looking um at
January's average length of Stak cuz I
know somebody had asked about transient
um our average length of stay for
January was 252 days for our eight
people that had left the residence so
out of that out of those eight people
that left the residence five we
considered to be a positive discharge
they moved on towards Independent Living
uh three of those were uh and then the
other three were reoccurrence uh and
they one of them was only with us for 4
days they were not ready um and when
somebody does have a reoccurrence I've
been doing this for a long time I also
uh at one point did work uh in substance
abuse treatment I have a lot of good uh
Partnerships throughout the community uh
when somebody wants help I'm very good
at getting somebody right back into a
level of care that they that is best
them uh what's like the average cost per
month is a sliding scale does everyone
pay the same or how does that work um
there there's different costs from the
uh from the level three to the level two
um so the level three is
$225 per week and the level two is $200
per
week and for that
$225 they are provided all the
Furnishings um all the utilities uh
computer access coffee cream or sugar
cleaning supplies uh and also uh Case
Management Services that are not uh
those are not reimbursable or some
people say we we charge for those
Services we do not charge for those
Services those are not uh Medicaid
reimburse reimbursable or at least we we
do not
so uh one last question I'm sorry uh a
lot of times people that have been uh
involved in crimes may have some type of
follow-up counseling or whatever do you
provide that service can someone like
that stay at one of your places or how
does where do you fit in the whole
pyramid I guess of um so you're required
uh so it I one of our biggest partners
are the recovery courts both maram
County and Hillsboro um recovery courts
I got the pleasure of going to uh
maramont County's recovery Court
graduation uh two weeks ago three out of
the five uh graduates were our residents
or alumni and then they had a guest
speaker uh that was a graduate of ours
about two years ago um so we have
incredible Partnerships with them um and
yeah uh if you are in a recovery court
you are required and mandated by us to
fulfill all the requirements of that
program um you are required to fulfill
all the Aftercare recommendations from
say if you just completed a treatment
program uh you know 90-day treatment
program if they're
recommending um counseling and uh maybe
an intensive outpatient then we will uh
require you to you know complete that
after care recommendation too because in
recovery if you start saying nah I don't
problem thank you uh any other questions
seeing that thank you so much for coming
much you mind I'll be very very oh
okay so if you could just uh introduce
yourself and who you represent where
your comments absolutely uh Mr chairman
honorable members the committee my name
is Jake Barry I'm the vice president of
policy at new Futures we're a
nonpartisan nonprofit Health policy and
advocacy organization uh we work on
issues related to substance misuse and
Behavioral Health around our state uh we
were we've been involved with this bill
uh we worked uh you know going back two
years we've worked with with the fire
marshall office everyone else you heard
here today and crafting this language um
I don't want to repeat too much of
what's been said I do want to to kind of
clarify and re reinforce a few different
points first off I I just want to again
level set and I know it was stated at
the the hearing and I know um you know
as we've alluded to here lots of people
and communities have uh strong feelings
when recovery residences are proposed
but the data is absolutely crystal clear
that neighborhoods that do have recovery
houses in them have lower rates of
substance use have lower of Overdose
have lower rates of of substance related
crime so I just want to level set these
are nothing but a benefit to the the
public health of our of both the
individuals who who reside in these
houses and uh to the communities at
large um secondly I really want to
reinforce you know there's been lots of
talk uh today about uh occupancy
restrictions um again you know as as we
heard from Mr salvucci from NH core
there is an occupancy restriction
related to you know for for their
certification uh 50 square foots per bed
uh I would I don't know offhand the nhpr
Restriction but I'm sure that there's
one there as well I have to imagine that
these are in line with generally local
uh local zoning regulations um a few
other points uh there's been lots of
talk about for-profit and nonprofit
issue I'm not entirely sure about the
the relevance of this to my knowledge
and I'm not a zoning expert you you all
are but I don't believe that local
residential zoning regulates land use
based on an occupant's tax status
doesn't do that for any other type of
housing to my knowledge and I don't
believe it it it would apply in this
case um there's also been uh questions
about the transient and non-transient
language I want to be clear this
language was based on the international
residential codes Definition of
transient as being not more than 30 days
occupancy uh again that's comes from the
international residential code uh and
again as you just heard from Mr Gerson
uh you know in this at his home's
average lengths of stays are are are are
250 days plus well well in uccess of the
30-day uh definition has applied here um
I think those are the main points I
wanted to make again we strongly support
this bill and ask you and thank you for
your consideration I'm happy to answer
any
questions thank you Mr Barry any
Barry good thanks for coming in really
appreciate it thank you thank
you okay does anyone else want to speak
or have a pin card or make any comments
the public comment section and we'll uh
everyone's get a few minutes to discuss
their bill within the uh subcommittee
thank
you
e
have